hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren ich trage diese Sonnenbrille
nicht weil ich denke dass ich extrem
cool bin sondern weil ich im Boxtraining
extrem auf die Fresse bekommen habe
hast du gefragt nein nein ihr seht es ja
bereits im Titel eingeblendet ich war
bei dm einem Drogeriemarkt in Köln bei
mir um die Ecke und habe einfach mal
alle möglichen Sachen eingekauft von den
ich mir dachte
[Musik]
57 Euro habe ich da ausgegeben
fangen wir mal direkt an mit dem ersten
Produkt was wir dort im DM in die Augen
gestochen ist und zwar sind es die neuen
bilou Kaugummi bibisbeautypalace hat
jetzt Cherry Coco flavour Kaugummis
rausgebracht slushi Apple flavor und
funky Cola flavour und die sind extra
spritzig
[Musik]
probier mal als nächstes Mal Cherry Coco
frei war
und als letztes Kaugummi haben wir funky
funky
geht klar
dass sie ohne seit einem Jahr was
gepostet zu haben einfach diese
Kaugummis launcht vielleicht gibt es
auch länger schreibst du in die
Kommentare ich habe dir aber nie gesehen
wir machen allerdings direkt weiter mit
der nächsten Sache die dort auch im
Regal statt und zwar das hier
1,5 Grad das ist ein bio-eiste mit dem
Geschmack Limette YouTube
oh mein Gott ich wünsche dir könnte das
Riechen ne
oh mein Gott das riecht
boah das riecht wie wenn du Plastik
anzündest und drauf kotzt
also es schmeckt deutlich besser als es
riecht aber es schmeckt immer noch nach
Arsch warum ich das Produkt allerdings
gekauft habe ist die Tatsache dass die
und das ist ja alles schön und gut dass
die komplette Klima positiv sind und bio
und fair und so aber die nennen das
Produkt 1,5 Grad
wegen diesem Klimaziel 1,5 Grad
Erwärmung Pariser Klima bekommen die ist
das so heftig
machen wir allerdings direkt weiter mit
dem nächsten Produkt dass ich gekauft
habe und zwar ist dieser Hut
wenn ein Hut tut gut
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt brauche ich nur noch eine Brille
für mein Auge aber gar kein Problem ich
habe natürlich mitgedacht denn als
nächstes habe ich bei dm diese
Schlafmaske angelächelt mit einem
kühlgelpad
mit einem iPad finde ich besser ich
verstehe nicht so ganz was ein Kühlgel
Pad ist weil hier ist nichts mehr drin
und das hier ist
oh mein Gott for real das ist ein
bisschen kalt hört man leider etwas drin
hier hinter
ähm
ja allerdings direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten Produkt und zwar habe ich
Garnier
hyalalala nicht auf das Gesicht aus dem
Popel
nee nee ohne mich
ich bin überhaupt kein Fan von irgendwie
ins Gesicht Klatsche deswegen können wir
das ja auch als sie direkt wegschmeißen
das ist nämlich eine Vitamin C tuchmaske
ich weiß also
ehrlich gesagt wirklich überhaupt keinen
Plan wie der Körper Vitamin C über eine
tuchmaske aufnehmen oh nein es ist
genauso auch nee den ganzen Teppich voll
ich fühl mich komplett voll mit Vitamin
C aber sollte man so eine Maske nicht
eigentlich auf seinen Fuß machen
weil das ist doch der Vitamin C
dann äh wir machen allerdings weiter mit
dem nächsten Punkt dass ich gekauft habe
und zwar ist ein haarturbahn aus
Mikrofaser
ja wie mache ich das jetzt
[Musik]
dieser Mikrofaser hat auf jeden Fall
vorne einen Knopf und hinten
nicht
ich glaube ich sah noch nie in dem Video
so beschissen aus machen wir jedoch
direkt
gekauft habe und zwar ist
es an Bürste
das habe ich halt auch nicht verstanden
oh mein Gott
wer sich sonnending kauft der hat echt
einen Platzproblem bei forreal wenn du
Platz hast um so etwas einzustecken dann
hast du auch Platz um eine ganze
Zahnbürste einzustecken also um so zu
machen die Idee ist natürlich ganz cool
aber okay
[Musik]
wir machen weiter mit einem Deo was ich
mir gekauft habe ist nicht bezahlt ist
von
X ich habe keine Ahnung wie es
ausgesprochen wird und das heißt black
night nonstop cool man Sand
ich habe noch nicht gerochen
ich verlose ein Axio unter allen Leuten
machen wir weiter mit dem nächsten
Produkt was ich auch nicht so ganz
verstanden habe und zwar ist es ein
entwirr Künstler
was zum ist ein entwirr Künstler der ist
auch ordentlich schaut toll
es ist ein Kamm
für so Hunde oder
das Haare von mir drin
habe ich Haarausfall machen wir
allerdings ihr habt schon fast erraten
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten Produkt
was sie gekauft habe und zwar einer
Familie Sonnencreme
Sonnen Roller
[Musik]
kriegt man rollt das über die Haut das
ist so viel unpraktischer und dümmer als
einfach eine Tube wo was rauskommt was
ich allerdings nicht verstanden habe ist
warum das für die ganze Familie ist
dann ist Sonnencreme das ist genauso wie
bei einer Zucchini oder Tomaten
familientomate ja natürlich ist sie kann
ja jeder ist so ein Scheiß Produkt ey 14
€ habe ich für den direkt bezahlbare
weiter mit etwas was du 1 € gekostet hat
und zwar diese Einkaufstasche die ich
nicht verstanden habe weil das ist die
kleinste Einkaufstasche der Welt
vielleicht war die deswegen auch so
schneiden wir raus wir machen weiter mit
dem Pan natural trigal Caramel salt
chocolate
alter Schwede hat das Ding viel Zucker
ihr kennt sie natürlich alle ist
tatsächlich neben bibisbeautypalace und
Katja krasavice meine lieblings
Youtuberin deswegen habe ich mir
natürlich
ey
ich habe Bibis Kaugummi in Vitamin C
tuchmaske und jetzt auch noch von Pamela
Anderson ihr äh Schokolade auf meinem
Teppich
wie kann denn Pamela Anderson für so
viel Fitness stehen und dann Sonnen Ding
rausbringen was gefühlt
selbst diese Tuch besser als dieser
Riegel
ach so die Schale habe ich übrigens auch
gekauft kostet
15 € habe ich diese Schale auch gekauft
ich weiß nicht warum aber manchmal bin
ich so ein kleiner Deko Fan
ich liebe ja generell alles mit
Architekturen in Architektur und Design
und alles muss man aufgeräumt und schön
sein mein Teppich ist gerade das
komplette Gegenteil davon ich ich habe
gar keinen Gebrauch für diese Schale ich
weiß auch überhaupt nicht wo ich
hinstellen soll geschweige denn was ich
da reinlegen soll aber ja
wenn ihr eine Schale gewinnen wollt
kommen wir nun allerdings meine Damen
und Herren zu den letzten vier Produkten
die ich mir bei meiner dm-tour heute
gekauft habe das war übrigens so
peinlich ne diese Schale habe ich vom
Kassierer dann scannen lassen dann stand
hinter mir so eine Oma also eigentlich
vor mir die hatte schon eingekauft hatte
eingepackt also oh wo haben Sie denn die
Schale her und ich so ja von hier in
dieser ja aber die ist da so schön das
haben sie denn was machen Sie denn da
rein so richtig in Köln da direkt
Gespräch anfangen
ja Wurzeln
[Musik]
damit war das Gespräch gefallen
weil ich einfach da was genommen habe
und hier und hier normalerweise geht es
in den Drogeriemarkt und hast halt einen
Plan was du gekauft ich hatte das
komplette Gegenteil davon aber gut ich
habe auf jeden Fall noch dieses
invisible gekauft von Herr hallo
ich weiß auch nicht was das jetzt
irgendwie sein soll weil es ist
angeblich in visible
[Musik]
krass dicker ich bin einfach unsichtbar
jetzt machen wir nun allerdings direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten Produkt zu mir
gekauft haben uns bei diesem Büschelchen
kann man
ich freue mich schon wieder auf meine
dritte Wirtschaftsprüfung wo das
Finanzamt hier eine
betriebsstättenbesichtigung macht und
mich fragt ja
was machen sie nochmal beruflich
allerdings auch schon zum letzten
Produkt was ich dort bei dem dm gekauft
habe und zwar ist es einfach so ein
Schwamm
ich fand den irgendwie der sehr lecker
aus menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßen
allerdings meine Damen und Herren würde
ich an der Stelle das heutige Video
jetzt auch beenden wenn euch Alter
[Musik]
gefallen